and just really quickly point out that
someone removed one of the plugs from
the cameras and it's not in the room so
we're just like like Phil's camera died
but they're all plugged I'm like wait
what and then we looked and it's just
gone the plug was just stolen by
somebody Cable's gone is it a uh should
be okay HDMI oh it's bad no no the power
cable like the plug for the camera is
just gone yeah it's a little Hammerhead
eight but it's okay we figured it out
because we got mad skills but anyway
let's talk about the story here we got
this from the kobasi letter
the two-year treasury yield is now on
track for one of its biggest two-day
drops in history the yield is down over
100 basis points from its high last week
Bond markets are moving quicker than
what we saw in 2008 bonds think the
system just collapsed
I certainly hope not but uh in the event
that they do I suppose the question is
what happens if the market actually does
collapse and this assessment is correct
if all of a sudden you wake up in the
morning your bank is telling you hey you
can't take money out just yet hey we're
not so sure what's going to happen or
outright this ripples through all these
other Banks I got to tell you I looked
at a bunch of Bank stocks I looked at
the stocks for some of the banks that we
use and they're all very very very down
and that's kind of worrying so uh Drew
what happened investors and Bank stocks
need to be worried which is largely
wealthy people you know big funds well
but whatever citizens aren't going to
lose from this and again your deposits
are insured well no no no no no no
it's these bailouts no I got money going
into that I get that cost you but I mean
if if the big companies go under and we
do see a Great Recession like event or
this is worse than 2008 then what does
that mean for the average person in
terms of their ability to get a job
their ability to find food or what
well I don't think I think the 2008
thread in this threat to the average
citizens and average banks are grossly
exaggerated I mean if you're a small
Bank a normal Bank you're not affected
by things going on in Wall Street you're
not investing derivatives or high-tech
companies your Banks aren't going to
fail because you don't have investments
in that your Investments earn mortgages
traditional stuff signature banks will
not fail yeah but what kind of real
estate commercial real estate big bold
Investments and and bad bets so that the
investors in that bank they should lose
their money the bank should fail and
citizens shouldn't bail it out because
when they bail it out now I'm being
punished everyone across the U.S gets
punished when the US government steps in
and bails someone else we will pay for
that you think the real risk to the
Americans is if they do the ballots not
if they ignore it correct so wait if
they do the bails then people are going
to lose money and and you know because
our debt keeps going up inflation keeps
going up and sooner or later you got to
pay for that and it's going to hurt the
economy it's been hurting us you know
already we're likely to have a recession
we've been in recession threat mode for
a long time why because the federal
government gave away trillions of
dollars unnecessarily during covid you
cannot give money away sooner or later
you got to pay the price the price is
we're going to go into a recession and
we're going to have horrible inflation
we're paying the price so every time you
bail out a big Silicon Valley Bank or a
Wall Street big firm which you wouldn't
do for a mid-size or small company or
Bank whenever you bail them out citizens
everywhere else not just in the US but
around the world since we've got the
dollar they pay for that and it
shouldn't happen so then it sounds like
let's just let them fall they should I
mean Bannon was saying that on Friday
you know he was telling Matt Gates and
Dan Bishop on this show resist do not
let them convince you to bail these
people out you know but I wonder I mean
if in 2008 they didn't bail out any
banks what do you think would have
happened uh well no one really knows but
I don't think it would have been a
disaster even disaster if the Wall
Street firms but who cares I mean if
Goldman Sachs and Merrill Lynch you name
all those firms that they went under who
did they lend to huge Fortune 500
companies who pay outlandish fees and
they're not the only ones who can do
investment banking their Investment
Banking firms small ones all over the
U.S who can step in and take their place
they should have had trillions of
dollars of losses and derivatives let
them take their losses 98 percent of
Americans don't invest in derivatives
they don't invest in these high-tech
companies so we won't suffer we have
some comments here people are saying
you're wrong there's a video of the FDIC
saying they only have funds to cover
around four percent of the losses and
the risk is real someone else said that
the FDA FDIC has only enough to ensure
about one percent of the deposits and
this will be a push to get us into
cbdc I don't know what that is Central
Bank digital currency oh yeah yeah okay
okay
FDIC that is something the government's
own there to bail them out so if we want
to bail out the FDIC for the 2500
thousand dollar deposits that's okay I
didn't want to bail out for the
investment beyond the 250 000. that's
the bigger Bill we can't afford you know
one issue is Bank consolidation in 2008
465 banks failed a bunch of them were
maybe all of them were bought up it was
like Wells Fargo we came out with like
four big Banks I could see another same
with the Great Depression that was a big
wealth consolidation you know they
bankrupt everyone they buy up the assets
it's always well I mean and
I I just want to push back a little bit
on the idea that they bankrupt like it's
not intentional like it's not like there
are people pulling the strings that are
trying to bankrupt other people so they
can buy up the assets or at least not
not all the time I know that has
happened in history but still the point
being like that the consolidation
happens because if you have a lot of
money and you and and everybody loses
money you still have a lot of money so
there's a bunch of opportunities to buy
stuff up that's what happens anytime
anytime there's any kind of financial
crisis or whatever rich people get
richer because they have funds to make
to capitalize on the marginal businesses
going under let me ask you guys a
question though so uh Tim Cass
Corporation has more than 250 000 and
that's the only amount that's insured
what if our bank went under everybody
here would be out of a job how would
people here feel about that you got to
be able to make money if if we're not
making money uh we deserve to fail if
we're not in the block because if we go
if the bank froze our money right now
there would be no paychecks for any one
of the employees the company of course
makes money but the money in the bank
that we need to pay the employees until
revenue is comes in because it comes in
doesn't come we don't just have money
our our customers our members they will
you know pay 10 bucks advertisers will
pay a monthly thing or once a month for
those three to four weeks if we have no
money what happens we just tell all of
our employees don't worry about it we
tell our our our utilities so this is
the question when I'm looking at these
tweets about people lining upside of
Silicon Valley Bank and you you show up
one down people to think about this you
show up to your bank because you're a
regular working class person and they're
like you have no money you say how do I
pay my rent you're a small business who
maybe isn't even one of these big woke
tech companies or whatever and you've
got a million bucks and you need and and
you're a business that you know you got
a decent profit margin let's say you're
doing 10 20 per month you spend 5 500
000 you make say six hundred thousand
that money goes into emergency rainy day
funds potential Investments then you
have your employees that are the bulk of
those costs and then one day your
paychecks bounce the bank says there's
no funds what do you do you should have
five bank accounts first so you have
1.25 million insured by FDIC uh per the
size of your bank you should probably
have a Time the five numbers great
five's not good enough if you're like if
you're Facebook you know no five is not
good enough for Facebook but for small
businesses you should have multiple bank
accounts a lot of people having issues
couldn't get their money out because
they didn't have anywhere else to put it
so they're like Mad Dash to open a
second bank account like have multiple
business accounts secondly I think yeah
if your company can't pay the people the
people aren't going to get paid that's
the deal you know get ready to live
without money for four months or three
two weeks or whatever I want to say
some some uh some words just before I
make the statement
Max Kaiser and Stacy Herbert
because
I was thinking today we were talking if
we had a part of our balance sheet in
Bitcoin
Bitcoin went up and Bitcoin has a
different stability and a lot of
companies transferred some of their
balance sheet into Bitcoin and so if we
were like some we use primarily USD for
all our liquid transactions but then we
store some of the value in Bitcoin and
actually pay some employees in Bitcoin
all those employees that money they get
in Bitcoin is worth substantially more
right now than it would have been when
they received it so I'm thinking like I
don't know if the intention with all
this collapse is to push us into like
like some that person was saying Central
Bank digital currencies or something
like that but it certainly has me
looking at my crypto being like it's up
it does have the intention of Bank
consolidation
um centralization of currency and then
um I think they're going to want to try
and track it so well they I mean they're
going to be any kind of if you use a
cbdc they automatically can track it any
kind of critical yup everything you do
any digital currency like that it's
automatically tracked they can turn your
money off they can tell you what you are
and are not allowed to buy that's
complete your money is completely
programmable but if that's the direction
of the water flow then maybe no no
crypto I mean don't ignore it no crypto
is one thing Bitcoin is different and a
cbdc is a third yeah cbdc doesn't have
to be on a block I just wanna I just
want to point out the rumors going
around and I don't know if this is true
is that Harry and Megan had their money
in svb I heard that and I don't know if
that's true but everyone's laughing
being like all their money's gone or
whatever either way it's probably a
scary weekend because even with Joe
Biden coming out being like don't worry
we're gonna pay everybody and get access
to their deposits or whatever how long
do you have to wait and where is the
money
again the message should be you don't
have to worry if you've got less than
250 000 there's no need to do a run on
the bank that should be the no for sure
the message shouldn't be no matter how
much money you've invested or how badly
the government will bail you out that
all cannot afford to do all that they do
is tell these big Banks keep playing
with the money like jerks because the
taxes to fail they say and it's it's not
coming from the taxpayer but here's what
Joe Biden's not telling you
the money paid to to the fdi's the
premiums paid for FDIC insurance is
intended for you the little guy not for
the Millionaires and the billionaires
and now what they're saying is your
rainy day fund is being given to the
Millionaires and the billionaires sound
like Bernie Sanders over here the
Millionaires and the billionaires are
getting your FDIC money from five cents
knuckle historically the FDIC pays
insured deposits within a few days after
a bank closes uh usually the next
business day and what they'll do is
they'll open a new account at another
insured bank and then send you the money
that way uh someone mentioned that it
might take a couple months earlier but I
think they moved pretty quick hopefully
if that's true then yeah I think the
small guy doesn't have anything to worry
about thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time